what's up y'all it's ray schremer and
these are some of our iconic tracks a
few
[Music]
[Applause]
we were in atlanta we were with with our
producers the ear drummers and we were
in their basement actually we were just
recording in a little small room no flex
zone and i actually just laid the hook
the first day
then i came back and did my verse the
next day and then i did my verse the
nature in the gym yeah like the same day
or the next day some of our homies heard
the song and it was like
man oh no i don't know about this song
we don't know about the song because it
was so different it didn't sound like
nothing like and then we put it out and
for sure everybody like like it warmed
up with people people like loved it just
the energy and like i guess the tone
what made us release that one first no
flex first is because how different it
was like it didn't sound like nothing
and how like bouncy the beat was and how
fun it was and it was like easy to
repeat for the people like it's like
when i say no flex you say zone no flex
zone
zone that's how we really turned the
song up we was in sixth street in texas
for south by southwest like one of the
first ones before it was really a thing
every show he did was like when i say no
flex you say zone and they ain't never
heard the song before it was like no
flex zone then we say the song they
already know the words because it's a
three-word chorus what's happening
fellas what's good what's good does mike
will steal in here
he hasn't lived here for like five years
that's good that's good he ain't around
you know that wasn't even the first no
flex zone video though we had to go and
reshoot it because the song got so big
yeah yeah but the first original no flex
zone video
it was the one actually on south by
southwest on sixth street
[Music]
and we was catching everybody just like
natural reaction and then it got so big
then we had to reshoot it and we was
like how can we make this as big as
possible we basically created a whole
world around it and brought mike epps
into it
man we always cooking up like
just random times when somebody run into
each other we we just hit the studio and
cook some
smashes up real quick but like sunflower
it was actually like one of six songs
that we did like we did like six songs
that day just chilling in the studio was
drinking bud lights like we was making
like this bud light tower
so we was drinking them after you
finished the bed like you put on the
tower and we just like stacking it up as
high as we could go and then lewis bell
put on the beat i was listening to the b
i was like oh this is like
different like and it just brought up a
rhythm up out of me and i just went in
the booth and just started laying it
down and of course it's all the kids
favorite song and i don't know if it's
because of the melodies or like the
spider-man movie but it's like
scientifically proven to make kids feel
better like i love those vibes like
melodies floating you know i'm saying
high pitched
it's the vibe
it was inspired by like country music
like i wanted to make a different type
of song like a country trap turn up song
so when i was hearing that v it reminded
me of like a like a western bar or some
[ __ ] like
[Music]
it reminded me just like you know horses
and [ __ ] so i was like how can i like
fuse like trap and it's like a country
melody and make it cool and make it
acceptable for all worlds i even had a
little accident like somebody come get
her you know like that was the
southerner in us i think that that
inspired that song
[Music]
it's cool it keeps getting funny and
funny when you see like a baby doing it
yeah it's cool to me that that song's
the real party started like the dj play
come get her we'll be in the club we
don't even got the mics everybody in the
club screaming that sh you know what's
that they screaming
[Music]
to give our fans something to listen to
you know saying because we already had
dead the shrimp life won we went on tour
everybody had loved it and then they was
just hungry for some more and it was
time to give him some more and we gave
him that it took him a while to catch on
but you know the whole time they was
catching on we were still pushing like
everybody already knew it he wasn't
rocking out and we started like the
whole challenge error oh yeah
tick tock video
wave you know what i'm saying before it
ticks out yeah pre ticked we made six
talk like every song after that had to
have a challenge it was tight it was
tight
yeah it was perfect time first out of
jail cause him and mike will they
already locked in you know they super
tight so mike will brought us he had a
big part of us coming up and he had a
big part of gucci to come around full
circle like that all of us get that
number one together it was like big and
coming from mississippi and do a song
with gucci you know what i'm saying we
growing up listening to gucci everything
so it's like we turn at that point you
want the whole crew
when the money talks what is
crazy bro i can't really tell you all
the secret sauce about that song but it
actually gave me a new way to make songs
them two-part hooks like they love them
just like when i switch octaves like
it's like you really switching you're
going from like a low tone to a mariah
carey note and it's just so fun people
to say it's just like
[Music]
like that high fish that falsetto is
like it changed the game bro
[Music]
well yeah it's like on there but it's so
low on there so it's like natural i'm
really having to go up there on that
scale
he just did it you know he put it out he
didn't even tell us he just did it i'm
like yo it's [ __ ] like
i got on twitter one day i'm like yo
this is so hard i wanted to make the
official version and reshoot but you
know we was all on different sides of
the world at that point but
yeah that was dope shout out to travis
the whole vibe was fun
loud
and just coming through reckless and
carefree and unapologetic like it was
just about being true to who we were
we're young we want to party we want to
have fun when we get money we want to
chill with the baddest
women it was about just kicking in the
door and just letting people know hey we
here i feel like that was the year we
was really focused on chants too because
if you listen to a lot of music like you
said no flex zone you got no tight you
got starter party you know saying you
got type of records it's like chant
records i feel like we was trying to get
down to start the party at that
in the movies and they want to time a
flick for the camera yeah wanna be kim
kardashian heard i was living like a
bachelor using my vocals for like
like a flute or something on the track
comes from my production side like
because i started off making beats
and then i like eased up into making
music you know saying because i was
making a beat and i'll be like humming
in my head
and i'd be coming up with melodies for
another instrument to be added to the
beat
but then i started being like yo i need
to say words instead of these melodies
and i just found out my voice could do
it and you know i just experiment and
that's scientifically proven that's what
the people want like you know say people
love to sing along to something like
they love veins popping out their necks
screaming like
like they love to sing it in a group
like all that type stuff so it's like
yeah we put a lot of that into our music
[Music]
unforgettable it was truly unforgettable
to shoot that video like we really went
to one of the third world cities in
africa they was really showing us mad
love coming out dancing everybody was
having a good time and ended up song it
ended up going up to the moon and it was
an eye-opening experience to see like
people happy you know i'm saying not
having as much stuff as you would truly
like you could feel how happy they was
like they didn't need like all the stuff
that we needed it was like it was dope
and the kids you know saying like man i
got a lot of little homies out there now
like and someone ended up coming to
america with us and like actually
starting a whole new life
[Music]
if i'm writing for another artist like i
don't really think about okay this is
sarah eugene i'm gonna write a song for
her i'm just gonna write a hit
and if her vocal range can re-sing the
hit
it's done like a hit don't care who's
singing you feel me if it's a hit as
long as they recreate it the right way
it's gonna go
with paper
jeremiah had wrote
the hook and stuff and like that so then
we put the verses on it and then uh doug
came and put his verse on and he did his
verse in like less than an hour it was
super quick i started this race in 15
minutes yeah we was at the studio at dj
drama studio you know what i'm saying we
pulled up to do dj drama studio thug was
sitting in there like this with his legs
up and then he just walked in the booth
and just did it right in front of us it
was super quick and it was like yeah he
was chilling and it was like super early
in our career too so it was just like
working with the was it was a super huge
thing for us
nikki always showed love and it's like
from beginning to have her bless your
track is like you know you got one of
the ones and he's like you know she
ain't she gonna bring it to the next
level if it's on the highest level she's
gonna go beyond the highest level and
she always showed us love even beyond
like outside of music like she always
reached out she was rocking with us and
stuff early on like before 20 platinum
plaques for any platinum albums for
anything like
she the queen
don't want to roll it out with that
third album whose idea was it
i don't remember i feel like it was like
a collective like yeah i feel like
we just wanted to like try something
different some of the fans really didn't
understand what it was and we was like
we're a group it's two people but we're
two individuals so we're each gonna have
our own side
and then ray sherman's gonna have his
side together that's who we are yes it
was like a slim jimmy solo on one side
swaley on the other side and then rachel
in the middle that [ __ ] was laying there
like he had smashes on their paraglide
all type of smashes
[Music]
j is great you know what i'm saying
juicy j like uncle every time we live
with juicy j it's just a matching energy
you know what i'm saying so i like that
we got to recreate a song that was a big
song for him for three six months for
you you know what i'm saying we redid it
in a good way you know what i'm saying
sometimes you can recreate a song and
it's not really a good song you know
what i'm saying but i love when we
perform it the way that people rage and
uh
yeah shout out to juicy j j
[Music]
i just wanted it to be like high energy
of course when i started making it i
realized it would be a good rage song so
i went along with that vibe but
you know when i first started a song i
don't think about that
me when i'm making a song i think about
when it's going to be live when i'm
singing it
you know when the crowd singer they
going to sing it times 10 so come like i
want to feel some type way when they
sing it i want to be able to i want them
to be able to keep up with it you feel
me um and then i miss beats like i
wanted to get down time and everything
they rest here all right three two one
you go back up here you know say i'm
trying to i'm trying to steer the
the singing where i needed to go to get
the ultimate feeling from it i see so
many fairy tale loves go back i heard so
many say they'll never love again
shrimp for life [ __ ] shrimp for life
picking up where we left off you know
what i'm saying like we didn't leave out
strung out on drugs or like just
something dumb we just stopped right
there had a great album you know saying
we've been living life accepting the
changes as they come one thing we always
maintain was create music and our fans
like been more than patient and it's
like we don't want to wait no more it's
going to be exactly what they normally
expect from ray shimmer you know i'm
saying melodies
beats everything like sing-alongs and
it's summer time so you know what that
means i'm excited to get back on stage
you know it's been a long time since
i've been on the road like probably like
five years so it's been a lot of changes
and i'm excited to show the changes you
know saying the growth he has shrimp for
life coming and it's just going to be my
growth period you know what i'm saying
you know we got strength fire coming
next you did